[Musique]
c'est important de dire aux gens
terre-neuves que on comprend je
comprends leur frustration
le contrat qui était signé pour 65 ans
aujourd'hui c'est devenu un mauvais
contrat pour Terre-Neuve puis on peut
pas réécrire l'histoire mais on peut
essayer pour l'avenir de trouver des
façons de travailler ensemble pour
bénéfice des deux
[Musique]
c'est 15% de l'électricité Hydro-Québec
payer 10 fois moins cher que ce qu'elle
coûte à produire dans les barrages au
Québec en vertu d'un contrat d'Internet
est prisonnière jusqu'en 2041 à 18 ans
de l'échéance et deux provinces sont
entamés la semaine dernière une première
ronde de discussion pour renouveler
l'accord à quel point est-ce crucial
pour Québec de s'entendre j'en discute
avec Pierre Moreau c'est ministre
libéral de l'énergie qui a défendu le
contrat entre Québec et terre-neuf
devant la Cour suprême du Canada merci
d'être avec tout monsieur Moreau merci
Monsieur Thibault ça me fait plaisir
d'être avec vous à quel point à quel
point est-ce que c'est important pour
Québec de de commencer parce qu'on
commence les discussions quand même
presque 20 ans d'avance à quel point
c'est important de s'entendre là-dessus
d'abord c'est important de s'entendre
parce que le contrat est en cours et il
y a un ressentiment dans la population
terre-neuvienne et son renouvellement en
2041 peut par paraître éloigné mais si
le contrat n'était pas renouvelé ce dont
je doute sincèrement si le contrat était
pas renouvelé ça obligerait que à avoir
d'autres sources d'approvisionnement et
quand on parle d'une nouvelle centrale
pour compenser vous le disiez en
ouverture 15% d'électricité qui est
rendu disponible au Québec par Churchill
Falls c'est un nouveau barrage et un
nouveau barrage entre le moment où on le
conçoit et au moment où on a en service
il s'écoule à peu près 15 ans donc on
est beaucoup plus près de l'échéance si
on doit penser à un plan B parce que
l'entente avec Churchill Falls ne serait
pas renouvelé parlons-en de du
ressentiment dont vous parliez au sein
de la population terre-neuvienne
monsieur Legault vendredi quand il s'est
adressé
un point de presse et c'est adressé aux
terre-nevis en disant je comprends votre
frustration et votre ressentiment
regardons vers l'avenir il y a un
sentiment que les termes vient se sont
faites avoir par Québec là-dedans est-ce
le cas
non c'est pas le cas lorsqu'on regarde
l'entente elle-même parce que si on fait
très rapidement un peu d'histoire Daniel
le
Churchill Falls en 1961 imagine le
projet de construction de la centrale
qui fournit l'électricité aujourd'hui
viens voir Hydro-Québec qui existe qui
est nationalisé depuis 1944 et demande à
s'entendre Hydro-Québec au départ dit
non carrément ça va prendre cinq ans
avant qu'on signe une lettre d'entente
donc en 66 pour mettre en oeuvre la
construction du barrage de Churchill
Ford et qu'est-ce qu'on va chercher on
vient chercher l'expertise
d'Hydro-Québec on lui demande de
construire la ligne qui va amener
l'électricité vers les consommateurs
et on a là un acheteur pour une très
longue période de temps qui accepte tous
les dépassements de coûts de
construction de la centrale donc qui
donc Québec à ce moment-là prend des
risques très importants et en
contrepartie des risques importants
demande à ce que le prix soit fixe pour
la durée de l'entente qui est une
entente d'au-delà de 70 ans si on prend
la période de renouvellement qui va se
terminer en 2041 le ressentiment des
Ternes viennent n'est pas basé sur
l'inadéquation des risques dans le
contrat c'est la perception qu'on en a
parce qu'aujourd'hui on s'approvisionne
à un prix fixe et s'il y avait une
erreur de la part des négociateurs de
Terre-Neuve ça a été d'accepter un
préfixe sur une oscillante période de
temps monsieur Legault c'est très bien
qu'en politique la perception est plus
importante que la réalité et il sait que
la perception des terres neuviens c'est
un ressentiment envers ça comme il
souhaite renégocier l'entente il faut
qu'il donne à son collègue Fiori
une bonne née et lui dire écoute on va
s'entendre avec une entente que tu
pourras facilement décrire à tes
commettant comme étant une bonne entente
pour l'avenir vous avez dit un peu plus
tôt je doute qu'on ne soit pas capable
de s'entendre pourquoi
parce que les enjeux sont énormes bruits
au Québec ça représente vous l'avez dit
Daniel 15% de la production
d'électricité c'est le tiers de la
profitabilité du grand-québec profit du
Québec en 2022 c'est des profits records
c'est 4,5 milliards de dollars ça veut
dire qu'il y a 1,5 milliards de dollars
qui nous vient des profits tirés de
l'entente de 1969
le Québec a un programme qui le rend
carbonneur à hauteur de 2050 et il va
devoir non seulement compter sur les
économies d'énergie mais sur l'arrivée
de nouvelles capacités de production le
fleuve Churchill où est situé la
centrale de Churchill Falls et le fleuve
qui représente la plus grande capacité
hydroélectrique au monde il y a deux
autres projets possibles sur Churchill
Falls il y a Churchill phrase qui existe
on connaît les bénéfices il y a mascotte
qui est un gouffre financier pour le
gouvernement de Terre-Neuve qui a coûté
à peu près 14 milliards à l'heure
actuelle et qui est pas complétée et qui
a une capacité de production d'un peu
plus de 800 mégawatts il y a un autre
projet plus bas dans Churchill qui
s'appelle gold Island qui est pas
commencé qui est un projet et qui lui
serait l'équivalent à peu près la moitié
de Churchill Ford alors quand on prend
les trois potentiels de développement
c'est à dire Churchill et les deux
futurs centrales on parle de près de 10
000 mégawatts et tout ça transit par une
ligne qui passe par le Québec parce que
les lignes sous-marines sont peu fiables
à l'heure actuelle vers les provinces
maritimes donc un intérêt là pour
s'entendre autant pour Terre-Neuve et
Labrador pour faire un partner ship avec
le Québec produire de l'électricité avec
un potentiel énorme du fleuve Churchill
et éventuellement l'exporter sur les
marchés des états du nord de l'Amérique
alors
pourrait devenir partenaire dans les
aventures dans cette aventure là et en
contrepartie de ça Québec pourrait très
bien dire ben écoutez l'entente dure
jusqu'à 2041 mais on peut dès à présent
commencer à voir comment on peut a moins
de rire l'impact de l'Entente d'ici 2041
qui est à ce qu'on est c'est le futur
projet ensemble Québec et Terre-Neuve et
Labrador et d'ailleurs vendredi dernier
le premier ministre du Québec et le
Premier ministre de Terre-Neuve parlait
non seulement du renouvellement de
l'Entente mais de projets futurs et les
projets futurs
et ces gars Island un mot rapidement
j'ai pas envie de renégocier avec vous
est-ce que Terre-Neuve a les moyens de
quitter la table et dire je reprends le
contrôle moi tu fais en 2041
si j'étais négociateur du Québec j'irais
pas m'aventurer à répondre à cette
question là parce qu'on veut pas on veut
pas humilier ou choquer la personne avec
qui on va négocier mais de fait à
l'heure actuelle la capacité de
production du fleuve Churchill dépasse
largement les besoins intérieurs de
Terre-Neuve et Labrador et Terre-Neuve
est en recherche de de revenus
additionnels ce potentiel là le meilleur
partenaire pour l'exploiter et s'ouvrir
sur les marchés d'exportation c'est
définitivement Hydro-Québec la ligne
électrique elle est là la capacité
d'acheminer l'électricité vers les états
de la Nouvelle Angleterre et là
hydro-Québec a déjà des ententes avec le
Nord Est des États-Unis il y a là tout
ce qu'il faut pour une entente et une
entente qui soit gagnante gagnante pour
les deux provinces et monsieur Legault a
avantage à concéder à son collègue de
Terre-Neuve et Labrador des je dirais
des avantages dans cette négociation là
pour permettre à Monsieur Fiori de se
tourner vers sa population et dire voici
non seulement on a négocié on a des
projets futurs desquels on tire à profit
et c'est une entente qui est gagnante
pour les deux provinces Cameroun merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces explications
plaisir de vous parler très bientôt
merci Daniel bonne fin de journée